يمكن لبعض الاشخاص ان يناموا لمده ثمان
ساعات او اكثر لكنهم يشعرون بالتعب عند
الاستيقاظ فمرحله وضعف اليقظه التي تحدث
بين النوم ولقاده ظاهره شائعه عاده ما
تستمر بين بعد دقائق لعده ساعات لكن يمكن
ان يكون لها تاثير عميق على انتاجيه
الافراد وسلامتهم دراسه حديثه نشرت في
موقع ميديكال
نيوزلان العديد من عوامل نمط الحياه يمكن
ان تساعد في تخفيف الاثار السلبيه
المرتبطه بضعف على مدار اليوم والشعور
بالتعب عند الاستيقاظ بحسب الدراسه فين
تاخيره اوقات الدراسه وتجنب وجبه الفطوره
عاليه الاستجابه لنسبه السكر في الدم يمكن
ان يؤدي الى الياء قدر المسلم
عوامل عده تؤثر على مستويات اليقظه لدى
الافراد بحسب الباحثين اولها مده النوم
وتوقيته فعندما ينام الشخص لفتره اطول من
المعتاد او يستيقظ في وقت متاخر عن وقته
المعتاد كان من المرجح ان تظهر مستويات
اعلى من اليقظه في صباح اليوم التالي ايضا
النشاط البدني فالمستويات المرتفعه من هذا
النشاط خلال اكثر من 10 ساعات عن اليوم
السابق تزيد من مستويات اليقظه في الصباح
ايضا تاثير وجبه الفطور على اليقظه في
الصباح فقد ارتبط استهلاكه هذه الوجبه
عاليه الكربوهيدرات بمستويات اعلى من
اليقظه الصباحيه في المقابل تم ربطه وجبه
الفطور عاليه البروتين بمستويات يقظه اقل
كما اكتشف الباحثون ان الحاله المزاجيه
الايجابيه وكبروا السن وانخفاض معدل تناول
الطعام النهار يؤثر بشكل عام على مستويات
اليقظه اليوميه للفرد فيما توصل الباحثون
الى ان العوامل الوراثيه كان لها تاثير
ضئيل على مستويات اليقظه لدى الفرد ما
يشير الى تاثير اكثر باهميه لعوامل نمط
الحياه التي يمكن تعديلها
[موسيقى]
مودي بيكون كله هدفي ان انا اطلع اجيب
اشتغل عشان اقدر اصرف على نفسه
ببقى فاكره اللي مضايقني
متضايقه يعني
انا مثلا
هيمشي ازاي روتين هيمشي ازاي بتاع يومي دي
حاجه ممكن تقتل اليوم من قبل ما يبدا اصلا
بدماغي شويه
وبعد كده بانام ثاني
الصبح يعني مش اكثر
ومش طايق حياتي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير وشكرا على استضافتي النوم شغله
معقده كثير وكل ما عم بنقدم بالتكنولوجيا
كل ما عملناهم اقل وعم نقول عم ننسب انه
نحن ما عم نكفيه هي بصراحه عم بتكون
الحياه عم تشغلنا كثير واعمل عم نخلص به
اوقات اقل واقل من النوم وبالتالي انهار
ما بيكون كثير همم متعبه لا لنذكر
المشاهدين انه الشخص اللي عمره فوق 18 سنه
لازم ينام ما بين سبعه وتسع ساعات يعني
ثمان ساعات همم هي نوم كيف ما في حدا
بهالايه بوجود التكنولوجيا والوجود وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هو الشغل هي اللي مرتبط
بشكل حثيث الامور التكنولوجيه ما حدا عم
بنام اكثر من سبع ساعات وحتى لو عملنا عم
بيكون اننا متقطع وغير مجدي مش هيك كثير
من الاشخاص وكل ما عم نكون عم نشوف مرض
اكثر واكثر همم بيعان ومن قله انهم او من
عوارض
انهم يا اللي هي التعب بالنهار والصداع
وقله الانتاجيه وقله التركيز والى ما
هنالك
لكن في بعض الايام بعضها مش كلها انام انا
مرهقه او تعبانه مع انه جسمي اخذ قص كافي
من الراحه هل السبب في ذلك يكون الرياضه
ليلا طبيعه الاكل خلال النهار يعني هل
يمكن تحديد عوامل ذلك
بشكل طبيعي بيهمنا نكون عم نحترم عده امور
النوم الرياضه قبل النوم مثلا بتاثر سلبيا
على النوم لانه بترفع من درجه الحراره
بالجسم اللي لازم يعمل الرياضه بده يكون
تاريخها على القليله ساعتين ما قبل النوم
على النوم همم شرب المنبهات ما بعد 12
الظهر بتعرف القهوه بتضل بالجسم 12 ساعه
الابتعاد عن القهوه والمنبه هيك كمان
ضرورا هم الابتعاد عن شهاده الالكترونيه
اللون الازرق
اللي هو بيمنع افرازات ونين بالجسم
وبالتالي كمان باثر سلبي على جوده انه هلا
اذا كنا محترمين كلها الامور هذه وبرهوم
من هايدا شيء كانهم غير مش بدنا نطلع على
اسباب اخرى طبيه مثل الانقطاع عن نفسه
اثناء النوم مثل الكز على الاثنين
التحرك الارجل بشكل مستمر بالليل وهالامور
هذه لكن الشخص بشكل دوري عن بينام بشكل
كافي وعم يشعر بالتعب لازم يتجه شوي ليطلع
على اسباب اخرى مرات الغد انقطاع النفس
تحرك الارجو الى هناك بالاضافه الى
الاسباب العضويه دكتور هناك من يتحدث انه
من الناحيه النفسيه كذلك النوم او تفكير
بالاشياء السلبيه قبل 40 دقيقه من النوم
يؤثر على العقل الباطن وبالتالي يؤدي الى
الصعوبه النوم والتضايق حتى النوم ما مدى
قبل ذلك طبيه
مش بايدنا بنفكر على الامور ال ال ال ال
العاط السترس والضغط النفسي واليومي
والعائلي والشغل كله باثر علينا بدون ان
ندري طبعا الابتعاد عن كل الامور قبل
النوم القراءه تعرف القراءه هي الوحيده
اللي بتفصل التفكير يا اللي ممكن يادينا
لعدم النوم وعلى عدم جوده انهم لما يكون
بالتخت دائما انا بنصح مرضاي ان يكون عم
يفتحوا الكتاب ورق ويستمتع بالقراءه لانه
هي الوحيده هي اللي بتفصلنا التفكير
وبتدخلنا بالنوم بنوم عميق وهمم ومجدي
كلها الامور ما نقدر نتحكم فيها مرات
بتكون اقوى منها بتؤذي لحتى اشخاص بيناموا
جيد ان ما بيصحوا بنص الليل بيبطل ويرجعوا
على النوم وهو كمان همم
الاحباط باثر عليهم ولا لازم ننتبه لها
علاج اكيد
نعم شكرا جزيلا تشارلي امراض النوم
شكرا جزيلا لك نورتنا من بيروت